here are all the special grade sourcers
in Jujutsu Kaizen ranked from weakest to
strongest I mean they're all strong of
course but some are stronger than others
and at the bottom of the pack we have
suguru ghetto his innate technique
enables him to absorb and control many
different cursed Spirits then we have
yukitsukumo her in a technique enables
her to Grant virtual Mass to herself and
her shikigami Garuda the mass added to
Yuki and garuda's attacks give them
incredible Force next up is Utah kotsu
he controls the overpowered cursed
Spirit Rika and thanks to Rika he has
the ability to copy the innate
techniques of others and use them
against his opponents finally the
strongest special great sorcerer is of
course satoru Gojo his innate technique
is called Limitless and it allows him to
have nearly complete control over Space
by manipulating his cursed energy on an
atomic level for a complete explanation
of Gojo's power check out my full video
link in the pinned comment